[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good tuesday morning there's a lot of
news going on
a lot of announcements to make
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to the tony
michaels podcast
right here on youtube twitter twitch
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central
live
on air as we speak
a couple announcements we'd like to make
gabe will be joining us at the bottom of
the hour as always 9 30. i think we have
rachel bitkoffer going to come on and
talk about
gas prices
the people who bought all the gas
guzzling trucks out there
really upset
oh they're
they're really upset about all the gas
prices
those big old trucks they got
are you scared
i can't understand why it costs so much
money to fill up their gas guzzling
trucks
and it's all joe biden's fault you
[ __ ] bought the truck dummy
you bought the truck
you knew what the gas mileage was when
you bought it they told you at the
dealership i'm sure so go trade that
[ __ ] in for for one of those
liberal toyota priuses or whatever
they're called i don't know what they're
called
what whatever honda toyota whatever you
wanna you know whatever car you want
maybe maybe one of those electric teslas
then you won't even have to [ __ ] buy
gas
come on give me a [ __ ] break whining
about gas prices and you're ugh
it cost me it cost me 500 hours to fill
up my truck because i had to drive it
across the country for the freedom
convoy
as i as i fly my confederate flag
because freedom in america
by the way i love putin i love putin
he's strong and tough he'd make sure our
gas prices were really low
you [ __ ] idiots
this is what we have to deal with in
this country
several announcements that we have again
rachel bitkoff are going to come on and
talk about uh gas prices
uh gabe's going to join us at the bottom
of the hour we might have someone coming
in here soon i don't know maybe maybe
maybe not
but another announcement big
announcement i want to make this morning
is we are officially part of the minus
touch family we are the midas mighty
uh
everyone everyone out there
who has been a fan of ours and watched
our show
has always i believe probably been a fan
of midas touch the mizellis brothers
politics girl legal af michael popock
the list goes on and on zoomed in
the list goes on and on over there at
midas touch and now we are part of their
umbrella the podcast is now being
distributed under midas touch and the
midas touch network
so i want to welcome all of you robin's
here katelyn's here lisa's here gail is
here christina's here hello chris in
hello
chris san is our local hate watcher
kathy hello lisa hello and hello debbie
salt lake hello
good morning carter good morning patty
ann
everyone is here this morning i have
someone here with me i'm not sure who
this is let's check in with this person
hello um
yeah you look like uh you're in the
freedom convoy can i help you sir
uh yeah yeah okay what can i help you
with
uh i heard you uh heard you were talking
uh first off just want to say congrats
on the podcast heard it over the cb
radio
the cb we don't broadcast on cb radio
but yeah and i don't know maybe
someone's uh
it doesn't matter i heard it on
i heard it on the radio okay right right
all right
people were talking in uh said i should
uh come in and listen to what you got to
say
yeah i would jump in
yeah so so what what can i help you with
sir what what what would you like i
don't like the way that you're talking
about uh gas clearly you don't know
anything about how gas prices work or
yes
i'm sure i'm sure you've come on to
educate me you know the the internet the
internet trolls uh have become
the professional epidemiologist they've
become economist uh over the over these
last few years i'm also an expert in
constitutional law oh okay okay it
sounds like you got your internet
facebook degree in that as well so let's
let's hear your internet facebook
ivermectin uh group uh take on gas
prices i'm sure it's it's just
phenomenal it's pretty clear uh if biden
didn't shut down the uh uh keystone xl
pipeline we would have low low gas
prices yeah i i don't get what you guys
talk about you know it's like you don't
understand how econ works like
equilibrium you know supply demand you
know supply chain it's all interlinked
you know the links that come together
for the chain you clearly don't
understand how this is in the chain
right so you think you think there's
links in supply chains and you think the
xl pipeline which
just runs through our country not
actually drops oil in our country would
help our country the other thing too is
you know it doesn't change supply it
only changes the distribution of the
supply right like instead of
trucking it over the road it's just
going through a pipeline
that's not what trump told me yeah right
i i understand that your facebook
ivermecton group told you one thing and
now it's another but i totally
understand i totally get it totally get
it totally get it uh maybe we have
another uh take on it i have someone
here uh maybe i'll bring in here uh
brett my zealous from midas touch would
you like to roll up this liberal liberal
cucks yeah is that what you say is that
what you're saying freedom convoy i
thought you guys were stuck in traffic
what are you doing on the show
you guys are equivalent look look look i
made it i made it about 15 miles out
okay
i ran out of gas did it start raining
did it start raining or no i ran out of
gas and i had to get i had to get towed
back
oh so so so why didn't you fill up your
tank
because it's so goddamn expensive
now yeah okay so let me talk to mr
freedom convoy over here i don't know
your name i don't know if you realize
your hat isn't actually a maga hat
someone i think is playing a break on
you but um
you realize that driving a a a truck
across the country you only need 15
miles i guess but you realize to protest
gas prices it doesn't exactly make sense
like you're spending a lot of money on
on gas
but i'm i'm i'm making a point
the point is what uh that we have to
drive
to show
well you know i thought i thought there
was about mandates you know in the last
few days they went from um mandates that
don't exist anymore because you got what
you wanted uh you're bought and paid for
supreme court gave you what you wanted
on the mandates so now now it's all
about gas prices where you're spending
yes you know it really does seem like
you you uh you you morons are spinning
your wheels over there uh literally and
figuratively right because i think i saw
them stuck in the mud somewhere
oh you know i i don't appreciate you
guys uh uh being mean to me yeah you
know like feelings hurt
i
i am the victim here right of course you
are
attacking me personally
for my beliefs and ideologies yeah okay
and it's because i'm sorry you don't
understand how uh economics work or or
gas prices you know right it's like
biden is you know he's in that recliner
chair in his basement and he is shifting
gears and saying
hi uh price is high price is low he's in
control of it all right so let me ask
you let me ask you because i i actually
asked this question on twitter this
morning if the president of the united
states no matter who it is if they can
control the price of gas can't they
control the price of ammo i mean i'm
just saying maybe maybe that if we're
going to go to the links of making sure
that the president united states has a
possibility of controlling gas prices
maybe we should make them control the
price of ammo how would that make you
feel
gasoline isn't in the constitution guns
are
well so you can't control that
so i i assume what are your thoughts on
communism yeah
i hate it hey so if the government then
were to be artificially lowering the
price of gas and telling the gas
companies that gas has to you know if
president biden really had the ability
to set the prices of goods instead of
the the market setting the prices of
goods you would you'd be okay with that
though
i mean
yeah that would be great i i hate
communism would be great communism i
high amounts for my uh insulin
medication you know you know how
expensive that is and my child has
asthma and it's very expensive for the
inhaler you know if if someone could
come in
and control those prices
right
so you want you want to apologize you
want to vote for someone it sounds like
you want to vote for someone that can
help control prescription drug prices is
that what you're saying i want someone
to go in and fight big pharma so i'm
sure you support the the build back
better bill which which did just that
right
that socialism bill
yeah yeah
that handout bill yeah yeah yeah that
one yeah that that one that one that one
see i think we're gonna run in circles
here the same way you guys are turning
your wheels and spending gas price get
gas money on um on uh
protesting gas prices and the the height
of gas prices as you suck up the supply
which only draws up uh the gas prices
even more these are simple economics you
know i've heard this story this morning
about how in 2020 gas prices were the
lowest they've ever been which is not
true and they're actually lower on very
much under trump thank you very well
that's because no one was driving in
supply if you're a real capitalist and
understand supply and demand you would
understand that but also you would
understand that the obama administration
during the obama administration there
was actually lower gas prices than than
in 2020 i'm just i'm just trying to
point these facts out i know since
everyone wants them
yeah that's it
the reason why is we had an economic
downturn because of a republican
administration when barack obama took
over gas prices plummeted to their
lowest that they'd been in history so
you know but but you know do you like
rewriting do you like rewriting history
oh yeah as you see fit absolutely with
your liberal agenda we love clearly
blind
[Laughter]
what does your hats i mean we'd write
all the history we want but you like
don't read the books you ban them what
does my hat say it says make america
great again again this is yeah
i am
a hypocrite this is why we can't ban
books i mean this is you know this is
the textbook example
i don't know where you're in them we're
learning that
we're burning
no idea how this person came on to the
show i really just get out of here did
you just get out of the meeting with ted
cruz and ron johnson yeah well you know
well there is a secret meeting i hear
there is did you attend that secret
meeting trucker guy whoever you know the
first rule about secret meetings is to
not talk about secret meetings
and whether or not
ronnie makes a great
kool-aid you know whatever but
so so cool now you're right ronnie's ron
johnson or what
is it yeah ronnie johnny you call him
ronnie yeah well
yeah i've already said too much
okay well we appreciate you stopping by
we really do um hopefully gabe gabe will
actually join us at the bottom of the
hour thank you mr trucker man i
appreciate um
all your hot takes they really are
uh smoking
smoking hot i really i really 2024. yeah
so brett so um
sorry about the uh the trucker guy here
i mean listen tony like we we bring you
on the midas media network next thing i
know you're having trucker convoy don't
you know your show well we we we we like
to be balanced and fair
um in in our in our coverage i remember
i remember a slogan similar to that yeah
well you know i'm not stealing it or
anything i'm just you know saying just
saying what do i know i'm just an
espresso drinking liberal well look at
you look at you with your little podcast
video is that cup filled with um with
maga tears or what's what's in there
maga tears are black
there black espresso
so you're getting you're getting your
jive on this morning
i am indeed because i'm i'm i'm excited
and
i want to welcome you and congratulate
you and welcome you to the midas media
network we're super thrilled to have you
and gabe on the network what you guys do
i think is super important there's
really nobody who has a voice like you
who is doing what you do um on the like
the left leaning side of things like
right
for far too often this space of you know
i guess if you want to call it like a
morning radio space but i think that
would even be diminishing it because
it's so much more than that what you do
here with the live stream and everything
right but there's really nobody
who is doing what you do on the left
side we're getting killed like we're
getting killed by these people and it's
being pumped into i mean speaking of the
truckers we're joking about it but the
reason why they become so radicalized is
because they are listening all day to
this crazy right wing radio and it's
happening now you know across the
country especially in the middle of the
country
it's happening now in latino markets um
they're being flooded with this just
lies and propaganda and stuff so it's
about time that we counter it and i
think you are the perfect person to
counter it so i just want to welcome you
excited to have the tony michaels
podcast
on the network and i also want to
encourage you know everybody who is
listening right now because i know we
have a bunch of listeners you know if
you like the show the best way to grow
the show and grow movements and make
change whether it's to get people to
vote or to get people to listen to
podcasts is by just telling a friend and
if you tell one or two friends about the
tony michaels podcast next thing you
know you've doubled you've tripled the
audience and then that just grows
exponentially and then we build a
movement and that's really how it works
at its core so well we're super excited
um to be here and i i 100 agree with you
and we i i think we had a conversation
when you and jordy were on the podcast
um several months ago about you know
talk radio and right-wing talk radio and
how it's had a huge influence on our
country uh in the wrong direction i
believe um and i think i think that can
happen on the left as well um i i
believe that the potential is there i i
think uh talk radio or entertainment
value um rather we're doing satire we're
making fun of someone or we're actually
just ranting and telling the truth um
and trying to get the truth out there
and as simple in as few words as
possible i think there's value in that
and the other thing i i seek value in is
that we're not gated and that's what
i've always enjoyed about your guys's
network always enjoyed about your guys's
content is it's not gated you know you
don't have to pay to listen to it
there's no subscription service um and
that's why we always have um you know
we've been working on this partnership
for a while how do the people tony power
power to the people and that's why it's
so meaningful
you know when you're in you know when
the listeners and viewers are in the
live chats you know if you chip in even
a dollar if you chip in five dollars or
if you
you know if we have you know sponsors
like tony hopefully we'll be getting
some big sponsors soon it should be
awesome if you support the sponsors
because this content is free it's there
for you and so that's the way that you
really sustain and that we're able to
actually do it day in and day out and
take the time to do it so thank you to
everybody who's ever you know done that
and also like i said sharing the podcast
telling your friends about tony michaels
i mean that really right there is the
biggest thing you could do um it's just
it's huge
and and i hope i hope that uh as we go
on we can have more and more from i know
we've had pop on uh you and jordy have
been on
yes
the popock poppin a lot of people like
the pop pop in here um
so i hope i hope that we can come on uh
and do a daily brief of of what's going
on in the midas media network i know
there's more and more shows more and
more content that's coming uh i've seen
i've seen recently that um michael cohen
his podcast is is now on video on your
guys's youtube channel not just the
audio but also the video which is uh
yeah it's a big step super super super
excited about this so
everybody knows and loves make helpful
with michael cohen it's like always it's
always in like the top of the charts
it's always top 50 like no matter when
you look um cohen's great we started
executive producing his podcast man it
must be like a year and a half ago at
this point or something and we work with
this incredible production company
called audio up um who actually does the
physical production of the show and they
are incredible i want to give a huge
shout out to audio up and recently you
know we've been working at working on
this for a while as you know tony
sometimes things take slow in the
background as we as we prep things but
we now finally have the maya culpa with
michael cohen podcast on the midas touch
youtube channel which i'm super excited
about we have two episodes up now and
cohen i think has done
i don't know hundreds of episodes and
the goal is to get all of them on video
but of course that takes man hours of
people plugging away and editing them so
we're working as quick as we can um we
got some great people on the case but
the the i think the visual podcasts
bring a whole new element to it where
you actually get to see michael and see
the guests and he's had some you know
incredible guests from you know
political icons to people even like like
ben stiller was on his podcast right um
so and and you know cohen if you asked
me you know three years ago or whatever
like
do you ever think you would have a
relationship with michael cohen i'd be
like get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
like i think i made videos about michael
cohen back in the you know right right
like anti-mexico right well you know you
know you know people people can change
and and i think i think i think he's
done um you know maybe michael isn't
done with doing the good that he has to
replace some of the bad that he's done
yeah and but i think he's on that
mission he's on that road yeah he's
definitely a road of redemption and uh
and i think you know he's acknowledged
it which i think is important and he
you know stepped out of it early on and
then committed himself to doing
everything he could to counter it like
you didn't see him
going out there and trying to withhold
information for some sort of later you
know payoff or anything like that like
he's the guy who immediately went to
congress and said how could i help you
let me tell you where everything is and
he's the guy for the book in other words
like bill barr did no he went you know
he's like i'll write a book but i'm also
going to tell people with all the
information like i'm going to tell
people right now where it matters and
and he is also the person responsible
for the new york investigations into
trump if you look at all the
investigations into trump if you look at
you know what letitia james says if you
look at yeah i know you know i'm pretty
pissed off at him right now and i know
probably a lot of your viewers are but
if you look at even the things alvin
bragg has said michael cohen is the main
reason why trump is under investigation
in new york right and so i think that's
you know super super important as we see
all these investigations i know mike you
know while he has to keep things close
to the vest i know he's been in and out
of the da's office and things like that
speaking with them and giving them all
the information that he has so um you
know just a lot of respect for him and
it's a great show and definitely check
it out on our on our channel in video
form it's great couple other a couple
other things i want to mention is of
course uh leigh mcgowan politics girl i
think her her her show usually drops on
tuesday so it's today correct
yes her show came out this morning and
that's a good reminder i got to do some
things for her for uh yeah right after
this um but yeah and the other the other
the other property that in the other
show that i want to mention too and you
can talk about both of them is on the
weekends now uh five minute news is
doing a weekend show is that correct
that is absolutely correct so five
minute news um is really exactly what it
sounds like it's it's uh bbc former bbc
broadcaster veteran broadcaster anthony
davis and he does a
breakdown of the most important news
stories of the day there's no fluff no
opinion it is really just the straight
unbiased news here's what happened one
two three boom you listen to that in the
morning you could go on with your day
knowing that you have the most important
stories without having to get in the mix
of all the noise and stuff and you could
you know go on with your day um so the
point of this weekend show is we're
looking at you know
not the name names chuck todd
but you see not just him but you see all
these uh
sunday shows saturday shows whatever
they just have they should just call in
instead of meet the president just call
it meet the gop or meet the republicans
because they just they reward bad
behavior and they're very antagonistic
towards anything democrats do well i
definitely don't want to appear liberal
at all exactly
you know which is crazy to me that that
they've gotten this cycle where you know
oh we have to be we have to be
non-liberal because they'll think we're
liberal which who gives a [ __ ] really i
mean so they make an extra effort right
to bring on fascist yeah and then they
push so far to the other side um that
it's just like ridiculous so you know we
were looking at those sunday shows and
we were like i don't understand the
format like it's just it's just not it's
not good for the country and so like
once again using the five-minute news
ethos of like why can't we have like
more straight analysis of the news
rather than this bombastic you know
let's get the craziest of the crazy
people on and reward bad behavior but
let's get real
intelligent thinkers on the show to have
great discussions about the most
important news from five minute news
throughout the week and so there's been
some incredible episodes of that i
believe we've done three so far and that
is every sunday at 11 a.m eastern 8 a.m
pacific that airs and it's just great
it's a smart show like if you want like
a smart show to start your
weekend or to end your weekend on sunday
it's
listen to the weekend show and i want to
also give a big shout out to
politics girl because today's episode is
actually with adam schiff representing
adam schiff which is an incredible
incredible guest um so you have to
listen to the interview with adam schiff
i mean so awesome so so we're excited to
join uh uh
the the likes of lee mcgowan politics
girl uh the weeknd show of five minute
news also legal af we have to give them
a shout out of course um and i'll have
jordy on to uh maybe uh get some legal
af drops um on wednesdays and saturdays
also also uh zoomed in is another one
and and then kremlin files is another uh
property that we're joining so we're
very excited here we're very excited to
join the midas media network and minus
touch brett i really do appreciate it
thank you and i know you probably have
to run to uh get some more uh some more
stuff out for politics girl it sounds
like uh
maybe it triggered you too uh i'm happy
you reminded me to
well thanks a lot we do appreciate uh
you bringing us under the umbrella and
we look forward to the partnership and
you know just bringing pro-democracy
message forward that's that's what we
want to do so full speed ahead and yeah
now and i would leave you know on that
note that it's really to me like it's
really not about
liberal conservative left-wing
right-wing like i was never even like a
super political person until
the last few years but when i look at it
you see
there's one political party that is full
on fascists that literally wants us to
be
russia
in many ways i mean you see what just
happened minutes ago in florida where
the state senate passed the horrific
don't say gay bill and that's now going
to ron desantis desk you had a state
senator there
get up and say being gay is only
temporary it's only a temporary thing
lgbt that's only temporary so why should
people be talking about gay people or
lgbt i mean this is the same stuff that
we're seeing out of authoritarian
totalitarian countries it's really
[ __ ] gross it's really [ __ ] gross
and then i saw a clip yes um that was
from yesterday but i saw this morning of
a uh
he's like a leading house candidate in
michigan i'm not sure if you saw this
clip and he said that he tells his
daughters um that
he goes as i always tell my daughters
and i have three daughters um if you're
going to get raped you may as well lie
there and enjoy it yeah i've seen the
video horrible horrible horrible
horrible so i mean when you just look at
you know just not even politically but
from decency from democracy
from human rights from civil rights if
you just look at the differences you see
where the stakes are and i see where i
want the country to be i don't want our
country to be the country of those two
people i want our country to be the
country of equality i want our country
to be the country where we could vote
where
books are encouraged not banned and
burned and i don't think that is a
radical thing to believe i believe all
the things the republicans doing is what
is truly radical and bad for america and
would transform america into what we're
seeing right now in in russia so that's
you know that's the note i want to leave
on that this is not really even about
left versus right this is about just
what is right and pro-democracy and i
think everybody needs to hammer that
message home that we are the real
pro-democracy movement here and the
pro-democracy party and that's why it's
so important that we all support
pro-democracy voices and go to the polls
and vote for pro-democracy candidates
well thanks for joining us we will talk
to you soon my friend and uh get get get
the tweeting you got to get politics
girl stuff out there so
all right thanks people good work tony
we'll talk to you soon thank you later
bye
all right uh it looks like uh hey gabe
how are you
how are you
it it what you know the microphone thing
always with the always with the device
that's how i know the trucker guy the
trucker guy that was on earlier the
trucker guy that was on there had no
problem with the microphone no problem
at all what
what sorry what trucker guy yeah
wait i don't know if you were watching
but there was a there was a trucker
convoy guy that came on you know to
antagonize about gas prices i don't know
have you seen have you seen the news
with the uh with the cutting off the
russia
uh imports of oil the gas is gonna go up
i just uh i just saw that news uh this
morning before i got on the show look at
you drinking that red bull ready to go
yeah yeah i'm fired up i'm fired up i
mean i got my coffee i got my ready and
my news huh yeah what yeah absolutely
great great announcements we also have
another announcement and i don't know if
everyone noticed but we now have super
chat
super chat so you can super chat super
chat so you can you can do a super chat
um in in the uh the thing and i'm not
sure
i'm not sure exactly um if the comments
show the super chat when they do it uh
let's see if we have a super chat we had
a super chat we had us who did we have
do a super chat uh midas lisa thank you
very much for the super chat minus these
look at that we can bring them in
um oh mj gave us a super chat thank you
for the super sticker oh thank you super
stickers we got super stickers too yeah
i turned on the the chat and the
stickers i don't know what the yolo yeah
i don't i don't i don't know
[ __ ] them right welcome so so as you
guys chat um and as you guys
get get the super chat we'll try to
bring you into the show you know we like
to we like to engage with you right here
on the show if we can um we're try we
try to keep up with the chat sometimes
you guys chat with each other so it's
hard to tell but um yeah there's mind as
touch thanks for having me brett says
and and we got we got a lot of new folks
in here but we always we always have um
the the the
the norms the the locals
as we call them
um
less lego batman today carter doesn't
want me carter doesn't want me to do
lego batman i i don't know i i was you
know last friday i had this voice
problem right yeah somebody stole your
voice dude yeah well they they took my
voice so i had i had to make do and the
lego batman seemed to
you know kind of be a a place filler
right some people liked it some people
didn't i think you thought alex jones
was more appropriate i mean when you got
gurgley in the voice it sounded more
like alex jones uh but you know lego
batman totally is uh
is an acceptable route too you know he
had it was will arnett you know right
hilarious well you know i i actually
think i actually think i might you know
you come on with the wigs and the hats
and the and the whatnots i might i might
buy me a a batman mask and just you know
i it's super easy to do man you know
i've got like i said i've got one in
that and see the what don't you have in
that closet by the way in this magical
door right here how big is that closet
everyone really wants to know
that is the mystery of that closet all
right will you ever do a video where you
give us a tour of your it'll be a really
costly class the closet's actually not
that big like i go oh closet and then i
i would pan this way and it'd be like
shelves and i pan this way and it'd be
the wall and then that would be it it's
just like a white closet inside so what
so how do you stuff all this these
things in there i've got this you fold
them a proper prime time sometimes i'm
like uh screw it and i throw it on top
of the box but inside there is a bin
like i've got my uh my costumes and i've
got film equipment
but in there sometimes it's like oh
whatever and i throw it on top
and because i'm like i'm going to come
back later and i need that wig and i'm
going to do a sketch or something like
that yeah well
well
it's all over you know let me tell
everybody you need to subscribe to the
youtube channel here so you don't miss
gabe's
um costume appearances
um sometimes he shows up
who knows
heidi cruz uh we've had eric trump on
we've had vladimir putin
um on there's there's been several this
morning there was a trucker on so i
worked pretty hard to get these
interviews you know i wasn't even
expecting that trucker to come on
well you know what i don't i don't even
half the time i don't even know who the
hell is going to be on until i click the
button and the person pops up on the
screen so um it's kind of surprising to
me sometimes so uh yoda's here hello
yoda
uh he said what's up [ __ ]
um
[Laughter]
okay so the the gas prices yeah gas
prices maybe we should just go to the
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
yeah let's [ __ ] on those gas prices you
want to [ __ ] on the gas prices okay well
well um let's let's start the countdown
and go to the shitless round
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to the shitless
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and trinity trends on the tony
michaels podcast
today there's gonna be a lot of news
there is a lot of news it's moving
pretty fast today
um and it's all over the place it's not
like in just one direction um and we're
going to take the band one direction
well i don't know i don't know do you
like the band one direction
i mean who who doesn't like a little
zane
no idea what you're talking about i have
no idea what i really don't know i
really don't know
i don't know one direction i have no
idea well i don't even know one of their
space split let's just say they went two
directions oh [ __ ] here we go let's go
let's get dude let's get to the timeline
here
so we get to the trendy trends instead
of listening to gabe yap about his
favorite boy bands um
here's some here's some trucker news
patriot take says um and
you know i i don't know if you've seen
this video yet and i didn't watch the
whole thing but what's that
that's the audio sorry okay let's watch
this here apparently there's some
certain type of flags that maybe aren't
american or patriotic as it were well
you know they're kind of close nazi well
they're similar
in the same camp
this is really weird like
this is this video so i don't know right
so
you know what i've noticed about this
trucker thing
is that jesus christ really not truckers
huh i said jesus christ look at all
those flags right well and there are
confederate flags all kinds of [ __ ] but
have you noticed about this trucker
thing like this convoy trucker thing in
the united states it's not all truckers
like like like just because you own a
truck doesn't mean
you're a trucker i mean it's got true
wheels and it gets 10 miles of the
gallon right goddamn trucker i mean i
own a truck i actually have a couple of
trucks but i don't i don't
consider myself a trucker like i don't
you wouldn't join the convoy just to
[ __ ] out and i mean maybe i could like
trump sucks right in on the side of my
box
trump sucks i don't know are trump lost
that would really piss him off but it
just it just seems like
they're not really truckers
the majority of these people
they're more like truck owners who want
to be called truckers right they i think
in their mind they imagine there's like
another 14 wheels
on their car and they're like yeah we're
an 18 wheeler you know and then uh
yeah i i don't think i mean i i don't
think any of these guys really uh one
know what it's like to be a trucker
because i mean right it's a pretty
stressful job you know you're driving
there's a lot of hours hours far travel
you know health problems all this stuff
um
it's not like that russell uh
uh kurt russell movie what was that one
with the the trucker movie that he was
in the trucker i i yeah anyways from the
80s
you go from one direction your favorite
boy band all the way back to 80s movies
let's just say i have i am a i am a
vault of information oh okay yeah well
you can't remember the name of the the
the movie but you know
yeah you know if i look it up people
will know people will know but yes these
rallies have really become
an excuse
uh for people to you know what it looks
like you know what i uh it's like um
it's not quite stolen valor but it's
like a stolen driver you know right
that's what it is right these people are
trying to
me want to be trucker right they're like
co-opting a movement which is already
dumb by the way to start with
right but they're cool i mean the funny
part is about the whole thing is they
were protesting mandates right which
like the mandates aren't even there
anymore because of their bought and
poured paid for supreme court exactly
yeah so and once these places yeah they
they you know they
i know new york i think sometime later
this month is dropping mandates or at
least like you don't have to require
vaccination status anymore right we've
gotten to the point where we're like
we're two years in
we've gotten as good as we're gonna get
on like the prevention side and the rest
of you dumb [ __ ] are going to get sick
and die and the rest of us will get
possibly sick and or like a slight kind
of sick
and well the other thing too is the
world gets more and more vaccinated
there's right less likely chance that
there's going to be variance which is
going to reduce the risk here as long as
there's no variance
somewhere else right it's likely that
they won't come here so like all these
risks are starting to uh
uh but you know how are you going to
convince these people right i mean if
they weren't complaining about these
they'd probably complain about like
requiring to wear a mask on a flight and
stuff like that like they'll they would
find a way at the end of the day they'll
find a way and they'll find something to
complain about even though it's not
actually like i had people in my
comments after i posted my video
yesterday and people were like oh uh
they're like oh i guess you you must
hate americans who are um
trying to protect their freedom
yeah or freedom to what yeah or like
their freedom from getting stolen and i
was like who
right stole
freedom right like who like what's what
freedoms were stolen you know what's
funny about that if you look at this
picture here on the screen it says trump
unity which is an oxymoron but there's a
little sign here uh
if you look it says build the wall so
like
their idea is
freedom but not freedom for
certain groups of people right they're
like in order to unify everyone we have
to isolate
ourselves well i mean i mean it makes
sense you know the freedom party the
party of freedom would
pass bills in florida where you couldn't
say gay you couldn't be gay
i mean you would definitely
definitely pass bills in texas that
would ostracize trans people yep are or
the parents of a trans person i'm sorry
why is i don't need we can jump into it
but why you know herpes is trending
herpes is trending that's what it says
i
oh my god okay i'm just gonna assume
it's it's it has to do with the gop
well you know
uh herpes you sure it's not it was it
was it was
it was on the right side there
oh was it oh on the on the last page
which means that it was affiliated with
it
right there trending other
competition
herpes
what does that mean let's let's look in
here oh
pandora's box
i'm just saying
is her beach trending because trump gets
sores on his chin and neck fold i don't
know
i don't know
maybe that's why it's trending uh thanks
for the tweet
thanks for pointing that out gabe and
getting us distracted see this is this
is why i do the shitless roundup we
don't go into rabbit holes i'm sorry i
just had i i said you i was like you
didn't have to do it but also i was like
i figured it has to do with republicans
anyway we can go back to we can go back
you know but look at it look at the
look at see that oh wait hang on
i gotta move the banner here for anyone
what is that what is that
i don't know maybe that's why herpes is
trending i don't know
okay let's go back to the actual stuff
yeah back to the the good stuff here
um
let's see
oh uh you posted a video about uh proud
boy
oh yeah
enrique yeah tell us about what he's in
the news for the snitch the snitch but
that's not why he's in the news
enrique dario's in the news is because
he just got charged with conspiracy
for january 6th
um
and
anyone who doesn't know who enrique
tario is he's the the leader of the
proud boys or former leader of the proud
boys and how they you know whatever
um you know
afro cuban right uh
pro white
so that it's weird it makes a lot of
sense he you know he wants to be
white
um
but also he was a snitch and possibly
still is we don't know if he still is
but he definitely wants to snitch
between like 2013 2014 for the fbi and
that information was released when he
got uh
brought in for
uh the the
the vandalism
charge
uh i think well more than it was like
hate speech for the burning of the flag
outside the church
um that's what got him in trouble
um and i made a thing i said you know
once that happened i was like dude he's
got a history of being an informant in a
snitch don't be surprised if this guy
rats everyone else out to save his ass
so
well let's let's watch this video that
you posted because it looks very
informative and real
it's it's it's real it's
yes i can hear you you don't need to
keep checking in every two minutes also
would you stop calling me caucasian hey
by the way can i get early release from
jail since i'm helping you wait what
well the horrific dc jail conditions
have been fearing for my life yeah
that's definitely not happening hold up
caucasian looks like someone's
approaching and remember there's trouble
i'm gonna say the name of a great white
american jesus christ great example
yo you're ready to make the buy you got
that white power powder why does he keep
calling it that he's going to ruin this
operation you mean the coke yeah here's
the money here
chandler being jealous [ __ ] moving move
into chandler banks freeze you're under
arrest drug dealer you're a snitch don't
be a hater i only snitch to get people
of color off my streets i'm white you
are his license says chip valentine see
[ __ ] also you're not white yes i am no
you're not your name is enrique tario
you're afro-cuban
that was the moment uh enrique tario
realized he was not white
at that that moment that was like the
mori moment of like he
is not white you know how did you how
did you get access to this footage by
the way dude i don't even know i find
them like on weird places of the
of the internet uh
you know odd odd spots
i don't want to disclose my okay
okay well
uh i i tweeted proud boy
terrorist enrique tario has reached the
find out phase of the [ __ ] around saga
of course he has um speaking of gas
prices
uh this is the presidential announcement
on fox news aaron has posted so we'll
get to read their comments here but the
president united states announcing that
we are banning russian oil
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
this is a move that has strong
bipartisan support the congress and i
believe in the country
americas of rallied support have rallied
to support the ukrainian people and made
it clear we will not be part of
subsidizing putin's war
this made we made this decision in close
consultation with our allies and our
partners around the world okay i think
that's probably uh the the gist of the
announcement
this is definitely going to have effect
on the cost of
oil and because of the supply in this
country because we do we do
import a lot from
russia now apparently there is a deal
trying to be made
with venezuela to
um
you know try to skate some of that
effect of the gas prices so to give the
audience an idea about gas prices and
how [ __ ] gas prices work because
we're going to have rachel bickoff
around here in a little bit to talk
about the messaging of gas prices and
how that's important because i think it
is important on how we combat this oh
joe biden's responsible for gas prices
stuff for everyone who
who is a capitalist or understands
capitalism out there they understand
that joe biden doesn't have a gas price
button on his desk like there's no like
he doesn't button that there's not a
toggle switch there's not a turn knob
there's not a button it literally it
literally he does not turn across and
told me right he just he does not
control gas prices but what he can do
what he can do is try to flood the
market with supply through reserves um
through deals like venezuela um because
he is cutting off supply from places
like russia
um but the problem is is joe biden
doesn't have the the ability to control
cost of crude uh opec actually controls
cost of crude which that's actually what
affects the gas prices which is supply
also and and demand um also increase the
price but opec controls the price of
crude not the president united states so
the actual person that you should be
pissed off at up that has the gasoline
button that pushes the button or the
turn knob or the volume up volume down
price up price down switch is opec not
the president united states again i
actually i believe that
the administration
may be making a little bit of a
preemptive mistake here uh i i don't i
don't think that they should be dipping
into our reserves he should be doing
what he's doing to try to get more
supply into the country through other
imports just because that strategic
reserve um this will be the second time
i believe that he is already in his
presidency went to that reserve and i
think that's a bad president to set
and the reason why is because that
reserve is
um is very strategic to our national
security um
yeah i don't know how much is available
based on the preserve obviously if you
know that probably wouldn't
you they say how many barrels or gallons
that they're taking out or introducing
to the market but i don't think they'll
ever say like we've got this reserve
this much you know like right you know
that's right
showing your hand there right but the
other thing too is
if for anyone
whether you're in you were in high
school and you if you had an econ class
or especially in college like econ 101
this is and this is like a universal
uh uh case study that's done one opec is
used as an example of a monopoly uh
right a group that controls the price it
sets the market
um
you know we've tried to break it apart
in different times but like these are
countries that hold these the crude oil
and they're able to set the price the
other thing too is you know you look at
1973 right there's a gas crisis that
happened then which is when you had cars
around the block you know it was like 40
bucks a gallon things like that like
another example that is used and it's
just like rudimentary form in econ 101
that explains like gas prices and a
shortage and supply and demand and
equilibrium and how new prices get set
and this and this and that right like
limited supply increased demand the new
equilibrium goes up to the right which
means the price is higher than what it
should be
and you know uh
it is funny because i get all these
people in my comments for different
videos that i make especially the one
that i just did about the the trucker
convoy
uh or even the one of the guy at the gas
pump
and in in there i'm like from big and i
was like one
opec is the is the group you should look
into as to placing blame right two
presidents do not set the price as they
want like ad hoc like if we were to look
at prices now 2008 you would see that
they were actually
similar right the other thing too is
that
uh you know the the keystone xl pipeline
that argument that people do
it's like shut the [ __ ] up that has
nothing that would have no impact that
would not be it wouldn't be done
to relieve any of the the stress on the
market right now i actually have a i
actually have a good video for that um
yesterday
um someone asked a really stupid
question
in a meeting
yeah and um i said someone
someone please enter jinsaki into a
ducey dunk contest um but let's listen
to the question that dumb [ __ ] ducey
here has and how jinsaki just slam dunks
this [ __ ] in the trash let's
listen do everything that you can to
reduce the impact that high gas prices
have on americans uh we're asking other
countries to think about maybe pumping
more oil why not just do it here
well to be very clear federal policies
are not
limiting the supplies of oil and gas to
the co let me finish to the let me
finish
she's like shut the [ __ ] up would you
you should teach yourself
let me give you let me give you the
facts here
i think they're important in this moment
we have been clear then in the short
term supply must keep up with the demand
where we are and here and around the
world we make the shift to a secure
clear clean energy future we are one of
the largest producers with a strong
domestic oil and gas industry we have
actually produced more oil it is at
record numbers and we will continue to
produce more oil there are 9 000
approved drilling permits that are not
being used yeah so the suggestion that
we are not and that's important like
there that's the other thing they're
like oh joe biden's trying to stifle
production like no he's not he doesn't
get to decide who drills where yeah like
there's permits these private companies
have the option to drill with those
permits or not and they're
back to econ 101 class we've got a
limited supply and an increased demand
for gasoline which means that the price
is going to go where higher so if a
private company
capitalism decides that they want to
limit the supply because they want to
increase profit margins
right well you know these all these self
all these self-proclaimed capitalist
when it's convenient for them they hate
capitalism and supply demand so that's
like the government should get involved
so it's like right do you want to do do
you want
socialism do you want the government to
regulate that market and say we actually
set the price or do you want this
privatized uh market this free market as
you want this thing that you banter on
about all the time about you know
conservatives and all this stuff like is
that what you really want or do you want
help when [ __ ] gets tough like that's
what it really is well you know the
other thing that really pisses me off
because they they pull these prices out
of these states
and it's like well a lot of states used
gas tax like the first dollar dollar and
a quarter of most states prices that's
for their highways like you wouldn't be
able to drive
if you weren't paying that first dollar
dollar 25. you wouldn't be able to go
anywhere because those roads wouldn't
exist yeah [ __ ] idiot you're like
spoiler alert tolls are also a form of
wages right right exactly
i i just i don't understand how they
don't understand this but it it you
can't make this make sense let's see if
saki can can make this allowing
companies to drill is inaccurate the
suggestion that that is what is
hindering or preventing gas prices to
come down is inaccurate would president
biden rescind his executive order that
halts
new oil and natural gas leases
well 90 of them happen on private lands
as i'm sure you know and there are 9 000
unused approved drilling permits so
drill baby drill ask the oil companies
why they're not using those right if
there's a desire to drive juicy you're
asking the wrong [ __ ] basically
what she's saying the party that wants
to drill you know he said drill baby joe
like lauren bobert even wore it on the
back of her jacket or whatever during
the state of the union i don't know why
you're chanting that to the president
he's literally not in charge of drilling
right
you are granted but here's the thing
gabe here's the thing though that's what
that's the
problem we have is these people want
authoritarians that's the sign that
these people want authoritarians all
these convoy truckers to say they want
freedom they want an authoritarian who
can dictate what the price of gas is
what they don't understand is under
authoritarianism you won't have gas
you won't get gas like i mean the people
who get to get gas like in russia like
you know the people who
that putin wants to have fuel they'll
get fuel the oligarchs that he wants to
own fuel so he can get his cut they'll
own fuel they'll have they'll regulate
who gets the fuel all of the big ass
yachts right exactly it just it can't
you can't make this make sense because
they say one thing and then they do
another they do the exact opposite like
and that's what that drill baby drill
yelling at the president because they
want an authoritarian to to take over
the drilling company and the government
owned them and the government what are
you talking about pick a lane do you
want government control or do you want
uh a non-government control do you want
a private
uh market do you want to do you want a
free market where they where there is no
uh interference from the government you
got to pick one you either want it one
way or the other way you can't have both
and you can't pick and choose when [ __ ]
gets tough because you decided at one
point you would uh you would take
advantage of something and then now that
you're on you know you're the one who's
getting the [ __ ] foot in the face
you're like oh no wait wait wait someone
else come in and block it for me like no
you can't you can't do well you know you
know during the second world war
when the united states entered the
second world war
the the united states government started
to ration things
and and people in this country because
they knew the stakes of fighting fascism
in nazi germany and they understood what
happened in pearl harbor could come when
that came to our shores they understood
one thing that we had to stand together
to fight and we had to stand together
against this idea that authoritarianism
could become fascism and what happened
was is a most american sacrifice like
people were they were they were turning
in like extra steel not even extra like
their pots and pans they were [ __ ]
they were they were melting their pots
and pans and giving them away and in
this moment in this moment where the
world is standing against putin which
that is what is happening and that's
what's going to happen with these gas
prices is the world is standing against
putin
because he is an authoritarian he is a
murderous dictator he is a fascist is
what is happening and
as he tries his his war crimes and tries
to take over ukraine
now
what we have to do in this country is we
may have to make a bit of sacrifice but
the present united states our president
is actually doing the work to try to
make sure that that we do not cut off
supply in other places and find that
supply in other places and that's what
jinsaki explains here at the end about
supply and it's funny that you mentioned
the keystone pipeline at the uh a while
ago because here she explains why the
keystone pipeline that argument is
[ __ ] bogus would president biden ever
undo his executive order that stopped
the construction of the keystone [ __ ]
idiot are you suggesting that would
solve the gas prices issue well i think
that that would maybe affect prices
faster than getting the whole country
here we go fossil fuels i actually i
just i can't even i can't even tell you
how excited i am to watch her dunk on
him again here because like what he she
almost breaks his [ __ ] neck by
dunking on him here and ex
he's having a hard time he's like but if
we
were not to
stop the construction then it's like oh
boy you're about to get something really
quick it's it's really [ __ ] it's
really it's really [ __ ] it's great
here watch this moment fossil fuels i
actually don't think it would the
keystone uh was not an oil field it's a
pipeline also the oil is continuing to
flow in just through other means
so it actually would have nothing to do
with the current supply imbalance so
it's it's [ __ ] incredible the name
it's literally in the name guys keystone
xl
pipeline right like it's it's the fact
of like oh we're not going to go through
federal lands we're not going to disrupt
an environment to put a pipeline in to
get oil
from
uh canada
uh uh through through the u.s you know
so it's like
yeah it's a i i can't i can't
somebody brings that [ __ ] up i'm like
you don't know what you're talking about
and then they're like well this guy on
forbes did an op-ed about how the prices
of the keystone xl pipeline would cause
them to go down and it's like
right now if they if they built it right
now you're telling me it wouldn't be
done right now it would be done a year
like 20 30 years from now right and and
the problem is is that
the murderous dictator putin will end up
dead in a bunker long before that
pipeline right whatever will ever and
and we will be back in a different
situation than we are now economically
with crude it just it doesn't make any
sense that that these um these
self-proclaimed free market capitalists
don't understand capitalism they don't
get it uh speaking of that we have
tucker carlson here but here's what i
want to do we're going to bring rachel
bitkoffer in are you going to be able to
stick around for a minute gabe yeah
you're gonna have to jump okay yeah
we're gonna bring rachel bitkoffer in
here just one second let's go to a break
we'll come back right after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face well now you
don't have to be introducing the droop
with our patented droop technology every
mask is uniquely molded to not fit your
face just send us a selfie and we'll
have one of our troopests mold the mask
for you elastic free thanks to the droop
i don't even need to pull my mask on
anymore it just sags that way the droop
lets you customize from a selection of
pre-worn masks lipstick stains included
make sure to order your droop today drew
be the spread you want to see in the
world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we want to talk about gas prices some
more but really we we want to get some
expert advice on messaging
so we we we bring in the great rachel
bitkoffer from strike pack
she's all over messaging all the time we
know you guys love rachel here rachel
how are you we appreciate you coming on
dude i'm honored to be here on this very
big day tony yes it is a big day we are
announcing that we we're now under the
minus touch minus media network
umbrellas so that's very exciting that's
very couldn't happen to a more deserving
duo than the two of you guys absolutely
and i'm very snobby i won't watch most
things as you know so well
everyone here hi rachel they're they're
saying hi
um everyone everyone loves rachel it's
the party it is it is
speaking of parties uh what's with
what's with the party of of not knowing
what gas prices are and how gas prices
work
how do we message this because i think i
think a lot of a lot of people out there
that are pro-democracy are struggling
like because it is so simple to say oh
joe biden he's
he's making the gas presses high and and
these morons just believe this stuff uh
willy-nilly what what is what is part of
that messaging how can we make sure
that our neighbors our community members
and just morons out there on the
internet on social media understand that
the president united states doesn't have
a gasoline button that's not that's not
how it works
i mean technically he's got a small
gasoline button but yeah it's exactly
right so here let's let's just kind of
contextualize this for people um you
know gas prices were in were kind of
pressured upwards uh you guys were
talking about keystone xl the reason
keystone xl got tanked even though trump
approved it unilaterally was because the
market didn't require it right uh when
gas prices are stable it does not work
out anymore because of natural gas
investment and other
alternative fuels eco fuels to build
something like keystone especially given
the contentious that goes with it so not
only would it not fix the problem now it
would never fix the problem and uh
that's why the oil and gas lobby or
company that wanted to build it gave up
um and in addition to that as you're
noting we're coming out of the season
where they've been blaming biden for gas
and inflation and it was a huge part of
their reelection strategy
and i really do want to underscore the
one thing about joe biden i mean if you
ever had any doubts about him in terms
of party over country this should answer
it because what he's done today by
blockading russian oil which is actually
a fairly small export for us
is going to drive these prices higher
and in some places they're seven dollars
in california right in la
so um you know he's he's literally
working against his own political
self-interest to work for the country's
national security interest right and and
that was a good serve up because there's
two messages i think that people should
start pounding and i'll certainly try to
create some stuff to help along with
this and that is number one getting
people to understand it's putin's ta gas
tax right what we call it every [ __ ]
time you say the word gas okay
so i'm trying to teach people every time
you say the word corporation gotta add
republican party because people don't
make those connections so you wanna when
when they're hitting biden tax biden gas
vita and whatever you wanna be hitting
back with putin and then that gives you
the moral leverage too by the way if
they if i mean if they're i would assume
they're shamelessly pursue this line of
attack no matter what it does to you
know the
nato or the uh international situations
that we're facing uh that way if if they
continue to do that then when we get to
the fall
we'll be able to position them as the
anti-america party
right well you know i just had a
fantastic idea and you know these ideas
happen live on air so you know i i've
noticed these these mornings i get mine
when i'm taking shits well
i get all
i get a lot of good ideas when i'm
taking this [ __ ] too what people out
there don't know is a lot of times my
best tweets happen while i'm on the
commode for sure
from the community i tweet from the
commode all the time all the time one of
my most favorite tweets that i have is
about michael flynn and i say i just
took a huge [ __ ] it smelled like a
traitor i named it michael flynn you are
the last rush limbaugh i know i know i
know so so here's here's here's my idea
because i've seen these morons post
pictures of the gas pump with the price
and then it has a sticker of biting
oh yeah you know what we could do yeah
rachel i would be i would be willing i
would be willing to partner and make a
make a putin sticker that says i did
that
with the putin sticker i love it yeah
let's [ __ ] do it dude let's do it
happen right that's right that's right
this is how it works this is how the
ideas flow that's how the ideas flow i
want to go to putin though and why why
this is so important that american the
american people understand what this
sacrifice means not just not just for
like your pocketbook but what it
actually means geopolitically and really
honestly you called them the traitor
party and it's not just their party it
is also their media let me bring up um
mr tucker carlson here um
last night this was this is his
his explanation of what yeah right of
why
why
putin wants ukraine which is a little
twisted but let's listen then we'll talk
about it now it's obvious vladimir putin
just invaded ukraine because he didn't
want ukraine to join nato putin
certainly had other motives as well
people always do have multiple motives
but that's the main reason russia
invaded the russians don't want american
missiles on their border they don't want
a hostile government next door now
that's true whether you're allowed to
say it in public right now or not it has
been true for a long time a lot has been
written about this over many years by
serious people no one knows anything and
is honest will tell you putin invaded
ukraine simply because he is evil okay
so here's the thing wait no wait there's
an important part play that let the end
of that card you want the end okay okay
putin may be evil he certainly seems to
be but he also has strategic motives in
doing that whether or not you agree with
those motives that's irrelevant
because what he just said there
was
he's been flip-flopping this whole thing
uh does putin eat your dog does putin do
this sorry not your dog does putin eat
you ate dogs just dogs just dogs does
putin do uh is he yeah right
putin say you're a racist did putin try
to get fired all this stuff right
and then he was like oh putin will
clearly is responsible for this and then
last week said something that was
pro-putin and then now he's like putin
is evil it would seem that he is so it's
like
which
which one is it man like we know we
actually know what it is but we're
trying to determine that right because
here's the thing tony and gabe both and
the audience too to understand the
republican base the people out there and
this includes right leaning independence
are not going to rally around the flag
rally around america versus russia and
the west versus this russian conflict
unless a republican opinion elite elites
like tucker carlson give them permission
to right so one of the first things when
this whole thing started i started to do
was really train full [ __ ] fire on
mate on shaming republicans as much as
possible on this issue of national
security and it's not just for fun okay
i mean it is kind of fun but mostly
we have fun doing it here
but honest to [ __ ] pete there's
always a method to my madness okay and
like the reason i'm focusing on that so
heavily is that if we do not keep at
least the chunk that we have now of the
republican coalition on the proved
democracy in the in this western context
side then we're going to be up shit's
creek in terms of national security and
it's much i mean it's as dangerous as
the domestic stuff
um with this party so we really i'm you
know pushing the elites because those
are the people that are going to give
the permission structure if you saw if
you did if you saw what were normal
things would happen in this kind of
situation where all of the republican
party was rallying around anti-russia i
mean it's the easiest [ __ ] thing for
them to do is hate russia it used to be
anyway um then what you would see is
biden at 80 on approval okay and you're
never going to see that with tucker
carlson working for putin
well you know that's that's the craziest
part because you know they they claim
they love ronald reagan and and all that
but they forget like he stood and said
mr gorbachev tear down this wall and we
are back to the moment where they're
cheering
not only for a wall here but they're
cheering for a wall in ukraine because
tucker's argument here is that putin
went because of nato he didn't want nato
forces on his border but if he takes
ukraine poland is on the border and
there's the nato forces there this this
because
because the and i say this all the time
dum-dums do dumb things and it's not
because people aren't intelligent and
they can't look at a map and find
ukraine and figure out oh okay here's
nato forces here but they won't dumb
dumbs do dumb things and tucker carlson
knows
dum dums do dumb things so he can say
things like oh this is all all because
of nato and it's nothing to do with that
it's all [ __ ] that's all bs and and
really go ahead yeah well let's think
about what their solution his work
around is right here his work around is
to um
tell people you know all right
how do i explain this all right his work
around is then to go [ __ ] on nato right
exactly okay so like oh no i'm not
anti-american i'm just anti-america's
world order and geopolitical dominance
by a nato because nato's not a goddamn
charity organization that's what donald
trump never [ __ ] understood nato's
about us okay and it helps the world but
ultimately it helps us and um you know
it really is just astounding
i i don't think there's a conservative
movement i mean in in in the uk or some
other country it would be this like very
small fringe minority of a third party
right there you're not going to see
tories running around which who are um
you know equivalently conservative not
as radical obviously because we're
played with this radicalism but they're
conservative people and they aren't
sitting there talking about how shitty
it is that we pressured putin into
invading ukraine it's all our [ __ ]
fault because of nato
yeah that's pretty it's pretty crazy to
see the things that people say online
with like oh you know if you
uh you know it should be very like clear
country like you should not be
supporting what putin does
but if you support in any way or
of ukraine or go against putin then
there is this uh knee-jerk response that
is regurgitated by people where they say
like well oh okay like imperialism huh
like like that's the
that's what you wanna
like one that's not it but also you
wanna fight and and make it about that
when it's not about that at all right
like you've got a guy who's a fascist
dictator trying to take over a land that
he
feels like is privileged to having and
you say hey
as a human you shouldn't be murdering
other humans to take that land right and
they're like oh okay all right so now
you're pro-nato okay imperialist and
it's like what do you think is happening
right now what are you witnessing that
you're willing to ignore right
well i i mean i mean this is this is
what they do this projection um i mean
here look here
the the freedom convoy people are are
are protesting for freedom against
mandates that don't exist and now
they're going to protest gas prices
while they drive their big huge trucks
and spend needlessly gas which takes up
more supply which in essence raises
prices but here is a here's a video from
russia from st petersburg of how people
are having to protest the war there
right now because they can't say war
anymore they pass the law you can't say
war but here's how they're protesting
this is freedom in
russia this is it right here this they
just can walk that is all they can do
they can't say anything they can't
dissident on their cell phones um
they're checking their cell phones yeah
to make sure they're not dissident
a bunch of truckers
complaining about wearing a mask and
getting a vaccine and that's the
tyrannical government they're the people
that kept me in my home for two years
and it's like no one kept you in your
home okay there was a national health
care emergency that we had to deal with
and we took preventative measures no one
was forcing you to do anything also
these private businesses made their own
private decisions to say hey you have to
wear a mask to get a vaccine whatever
yeah no [ __ ] dave i mean here's the
thing like they had to they in other
countries where they didn't just let it
rip and kill a million people okay
because most western democracies didn't
do that
here
we did and that's because people could
go outside in other countries their
quarantines were enforced okay if you
had to be headed to her for a work to
leave your house and even then it was
you know you had you you could get
stopped on the street and asked to
produce proof that you should be out we
didn't quarantine like that uh nothing
like that it ever happened in america
not even in the bluest places so these
whiny little [ __ ] with their little
truck protest i was so i'm so glad that
you know we're watching women deposit
their young children into strangers arms
on trains and then turning around to
pick up rifles to sit side by side with
their husbands to try to defend their
fleeting democracy because ukrainians
don't know better than almost any
[ __ ] buddy in the west right it's
better to live free
or die die fighting and live on your
knees right you know i i i think we read
each other's minds we are always on the
same page look at the video that i had
queued up here let me play this this is
of ukrainian women now this isn't
cosplay for for lauren beaubert uh
marjorie taylor green or thomas matthew
massey you bunch of cosplay [ __ ] this
is real [ __ ] these women are gonna go
actually fight in war to defend their
country not give some [ __ ] some sort
of cosplay for a christmas card here's
the real thing
um
that's uh very intimidating and
something again like you mentioned
lauren but like you would never see
lauren bobert
or anyone of the republican party
actually
pick up arms and go defend their country
instead they'll put a bazooka on their
back and walk into a subway and order a
12-inch you know sandwich right like
these are people who are like oh my
freedoms and it's like no one is taking
them away
so shut the [ __ ] up like that at the end
like no one no one is no one is
searching your phone on the street in
search and going through social media to
say that anything was anti-russia and
then say oh you know what we're gonna
boot you away and put you in jail or
make you serve in our military no one's
doing that that is actually the the
tyrannical government that you are
afraid of that [ __ ] never happened in
the u.s our government is so
anti-tyrannical and this is gonna be my
last i have to hard exit right now yeah
but this is this our government is so
anti-tyrannical that when you try to
pull for know plot a coup
a seizure of power and a legal seizure
of power that call culminates in a in a
armed attack on the nation's capital
even then like it takes a year
to like the wheels of justice to begin
to even turn right like that's freedom
[ __ ] i gotta go
thanks rachel we appreciate you joining
us come back any time we'll see you next
week have a good one putin stickers
putin stickers i'll be i'll be in we're
on it next week you guys are very guys
better keep following us
let's do the putin stickers thanks
rachel
that i i love having rachel on with the
messaging and everything um speaking
speaking of people who think government
is tyrannical i was going to pull up
this this video the next villain in the
franchise this is [ __ ] ridiculous
this [ __ ] here is talking number one is
talking to alex jones here um let me
pull the the banner is that top wine no
that's cork wine in the back what did i
say [ __ ] i don't know who knows with
this
trunt um
but uh she's talking to alex jones here
right
on infowars band video you can ban video
sounds like a goddamn porn site i just
want to say why in the [ __ ] does he do
that
why does he do that like i
if i go to okay i'm gonna regret i'm
gonna just incognito right now hold on
what we should do what we should do
is we should we should put a thing on
all our videos that says like uh uh
canceled cancelled content or something
like that this is cancelled
i i don't even know i mean like
obviously it's his or someone you know
streaming live tv uh but this
it just makes it sound like if you're
like oh hey did you go to band video
it's been like and you're like what and
you're like yeah band up video dude
right but this video is bad dude these
videos are unfiltered and you're like
talking
like it literally sounds like a site
that you would go and find porn right
right like some some really salacious
porn by the way which if you're into
this sort of thing maybe this will be
your thing but here here this morons
talking about the tyrannical government
that she chose not to follow the rule
listen to this funds but yet they take
the money straight out of my check
so i work for free in congress because
they take all my money away wow
what's right
so she's talking about how she didn't
wear masks and she was told that if she
didn't wear a mask that's fine that's a
choice you're making you're going to be
fine if you make that choice
what she doesn't understand is in russia
like
because she loves russia she loves
[ __ ] putin he's so strong he's such a
great leader he can't he won't stand
within 60 feet of another [ __ ] human
being right
like let alone let alone let you in the
room knucklehead and also
she's here
she's she's complaining about something
she took an action she was warned about
the action she took an action right she
was told what the consequence would be
of her action and then the consequences
were there exactly she still took the
action and she thought oh this won't
affect me it's not going to happen to me
and then she got the consequence that
she was warned about it it wasn't like
out of the blue like oh we're finding
you five hundred a thousand fifteen
hundred whatever it is each time it goes
up it was literally
here's a warning wear the mask that's
all i gotta do like just wear the
[ __ ] mask just do that okay it's not
hard it's a hard you can breathe it's
super easy
you don't want to wear a mask you got
fined you got fine you got fine you got
fined you keep doing it
because you want to fight the system
well i'm sorry but you were warned that
you would have money taken out of your
paycheck so no one's stealing the money
from you no one's taking the money from
you you're the one who's giving up the
money that's what it is
she's a [ __ ] bonehead everyone's
pointing out that she work working right
like
how did she act what she actually do joe
says here
she works she works
she's not on any committee i don't know
what she does right besides putting
she goes to the floor of the house
without a mask on and gets fined right
and then she you know probably puts up
some anti-trans thing on the wall across
from you know representative who has a
trans child you know that's a type of
disgusting [ __ ] margery taylor green
is right well the person speaking of
marjory taylor green pedro shakes points
out the good uh a valid point here
marjorie shailer green has officially
filed for her re-election as a
republican the republican party is okay
with members attending white national
conference she's a nazi right she's
she's a [ __ ] exactly why you know i
i don't well i also say this whether it
was effective or not or whether we just
drown them out i don't hear a lot of
let's go brandon that often anymore and
i don't know if it's because of the
association with uh yeah
nazis
but
i mean
yeah oh speaking of nazis yeah speaking
of nazis uh here lincoln project uh took
the uh
i don't know if you've been watching
video from from ukraine but all the
russian uh tanks and vehicles have a z
on them i'm not sure what that means i
don't know actually i mean i've noticed
that the russian vehicles have a z uh
but here it's uh obviously the former
guy the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopy pants himself in a vehicle and uh
lincoln project has put a z
on the side of it so it looks about
right so uh yeah that that um that
sounds about right to me uh putin's
little puppet there uh and
rick wilson said no lies detected i
believe he is part of the russian
federation as it were um mayo says um
about tucker carlson
and putin tucker carlson is trying to
start world war three and he's rooting
for vladimir putin um
is the guy that will intentionally start
world war three and then go i'm just
didn't quit what does he say he's like
uh i'm just asking questions right i'm
just i'm just
can a person ask reasonable questions
i'm just an inquisitive mind right i'm
just asking questions right yeah you as
the americans are not okay with world
war three what is wrong with you you're
right it's
speaking speaking of uh
morons
and asking asking questions and having
dumb answers to those questions did you
see that did you see this [ __ ] video
by the good liars with this i haven't
seen the original i've seen people who
have done lip synced versions of this
which is pretty funny god you have yeah
okay so so if no one knows this is at a
part of the trucker convoy
um and the good liars are asking uh
questions to one of the truckers here
and she has some really good information
that everyone should know let's let's
listen really concerned about right now
i don't want them to digitalis
you don't want them what the digitalis
she doesn't want them to digitize do you
know what digital is you're in you're in
the i.t world yeah what does digital
mean she's speaking of actually a
technology that hasn't really been
released yet it's about five to ten
years out okay and it's where uh it's a
combination of like right now everyone's
like oh you know digitize it and make us
an avatar right and then there's the
company tile that's a tracking uh a
piece of hardware you can have it on
your keys in your wallet so it's like
you're able to oh see i thought i
thought it was like tile like tile on a
floor no no no no no basically
digitize
it's a tech it's a it's a like i said
she's uh she's on the cutting edge here
of some some new technology basically
digital is turning yourself
into a tracking ship oh a walking
tracking ship you know okay well let's
see what else she has to say here i
don't want to take medicine that'll hurt
people what was the what was the word
you used though i haven't heard that
digital
digital
digital
and what what does that mean
they're trying to
they're trying to make us robots they're
trying to see but gabe see they're
trying to make us robots exactly yeah we
are in we we are walking walking talking
avatar
tracking unit i'm telling you i don't
know what you're gonna say so
so is this because this new technology
um where they
they obviously
give you an injection of a
a microscopic chip that you can't even
see i would assume could to get to the
well what happened it's got it's got
these nano bots inside the vaccine okay
okay what happens have you ever seen
jason have you ever seen jason i don't
know why you're laughing have you ever
seen jason x
no okay well in the movie jason x um
it's in it takes place in the future and
jason like how far into the future like
20 25 or 20 like 2030 i think oh okay i
don't i don't know the exact so within
this within this 10 years where this
technology is going to come out they're
in space it could be it could be after
that
right uh but basically
jason gets
on board of this spaceship and they've
got this nanotechnology and the
nanotechnology is used because it's like
theoretically can be used to repair
damage done
um and fix uh cuts and scrapes and
breaks and this all right and attack
like viruses
and in the movie
it turns jason into jason x where he's
like half row you know robot you know
we're like you know half like dead oh so
that's where the x comes in is jason but
he's now x yeah exactly and so
uh that is what's gonna happen right so
you got these nanobots inside the
vaccine they go through your bloodstream
they jump onto every sort of uh bit of
your being and you become digitized
digitized so this isn't like tai o i was
confused i thought this was yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
this isn't like uh
no yeah no
no no floor tiles no kitchen tiles i
know i thought it was like a like a
digitized backsplash or something let's
no no no
to make it where we have no choice and
nothing to where they control they can
control us from what they put in our
bodies
and eventually we'll we'll actually be
robots
according to what they're saying not
robots but according to what they've
already got uh yeah full
man-made working female robot
full man-made working female robot she's
referring to the sex rope well not all
no no no those are those are those are
those are some completely different
games yeah she's never we shouldn't
mention any brands because maybe we'll
get a sponsor eventually but
but those are completely different yeah
those are not robots those are something
that are completely different they're
robots they're technically robots right
you you get i don't you buy it from
another country it ships to your house
and you have how do you know these
things
don't don't don't don't act like you
know don't act like you haven't
investigated this at all
um so what are no you know i don't know
look look it doesn't matter man-made
email robot is she talking because i i
think what she's talking about is she's
talking about the video of the robot
that has like a that has like a face and
she's
no it kind of looks weird no that's not
it
i don't think that i mean that that to
me is more like a robot than the the sex
dolls uh
those dolls are like made of silicone
and you can move them and i think they
might be able to move their mouth like a
robot
all right all right all right look you
know we're on youtube and we're not like
kid friendly we don't we don't claim to
be family friendly but i i don't i don't
want to i don't want to get too far in
the weeds here with you and your
expertise on sex that's as much as i
know i only know about jason x the robot
and the other these other man-made
female robots
it's very confusing it's all confusing
again i thought i thought we were going
to be tiling a shower with digital tiles
i didn't no no making a backsplash but i
mean you are making a bit of a splash
right on
it does well it does i won't go there
where where the [ __ ] do they learn this
like where do they get this stuff
probably people like alex jones or they
watch some video right they watch like
the boston dynamics video of like the
robot that's like uh
the the drones or like wait wait wait is
that the one that's walking around
that's that's yeah the one where they
always test and everyone's like well
what is it called what is it called
again
boston dynamics i believe is the name
let's see if i can find that video
associated with mit
right but it's the ones it's the ones
that you like they had the walking dog
ones the the cops have they had one that
was that was they bought some for new
york
but it's the same like there is a
literal episode in black mirror
where they have
uh these
uh
these watch dogs and their robots and
it's that [ __ ] and they're chasing these
two people who break into a house it's a
very good episode i mean the whole the
whole series is very good
but
uh yeah this isn't a female robot i i
don't know i don't know if it you throw
one of those you throw one of those
silicone heads on it because well it
might be very intimidating female robot
but this is a video of boston dynamics
maybe this
is the type of robot that this lady
thought she was going to turn into let's
let's watch this like a
terminator oh let me look at that listen
that's sexy music
yeah well i'm going to turn the music
off because i don't want to get banged
on youtube right for the music but look
at that
um this thing even jumps over the log
yeah no there's the dog robot dude look
add add another add another four legs on
that thing and that thing will be the
scariest goddamn spider i've ever seen
right right right but maybe maybe they
watch videos like this and like do you
think that lady's like i wish i was a
robot
and she want to be like the bionic woman
i do like that story it's [ __ ]
confusing there there's the dog again
there's the dog again but
it's just creepy because the other thing
is they train we're gonna do these
[ __ ] stairs right but they train
these things
to like have almost perfect balance
they're always now wait a second now
wait a second so you're saying this
isn't like someone
does someone have a remote control here
or is this thing just doing this stuff
no this is doing this stuff they're
setting it on a course and they're
they're
it's scanning the area here's insane
another one right
here's another one jumping around do you
say i want you to go from point a to
point b look at that and hear obstacles
doing [ __ ] backflips and [ __ ]
look at that jumping from from platform
to platform that's [ __ ] crazy now um
this lady's talking about the vaccine
so you go from from vaccine bad medicine
going to make you sick and kill you
which is the exact opposite two these
are the type of robots that you're going
to become
and and what's crazy is
she is saying that you're going to
become a man-made female robot so not
only not only are you going to are you
going to die first and then man is going
to make you into
a machine i'm not sure what you're
talking about yeah i don't know
it's like the opposite of bicentennial
man you ever seen a movie yeah yeah
where the robot becomes a human right
right right yeah the opposite though is
done where so it's backwards so it's
like benjamin button
uh uh uh by bicentennial man is that
what yeah exactly yeah yeah sounds like
a great movie i'd probably watch it i
you know backwards bicentennial man like
benjamin button right i don't know i'm
just saying this is [ __ ] this
i how they their mind get in these
[ __ ] loops of this garbage and not
only not only is her mind in this loop
she's willing to say it in a microphone
and a camera but she's also willing to
get into a semi truck and drive halfway
across the country right to say this
[ __ ] to to believe in this garbage what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
uh yeah i don't know these people i mean
you look at the city like oh god
humanity we are so [ __ ] right now and
then you know it's like everyone agrees
these probably aren't the best idea
but
uh yeah well right i'm bro i mean i'm
not saying that that the the movie
terminator and then you see some of
these robots and you're like um baby
it's gonna happen it's starting it's
starting to get that skynet feeling
right like we're starting to get you
know what's going to happen mike lindell
said he's going to sue all of the
machines he said i'm going to swallow
what he's talking about maybe maybe
skynet is that what
these these robots these machines
they're going to come after mike lindell
well they might they might what you know
you never know maybe that's maybe that's
the new plot of terminator see i think
that's the other thing that really
gets in these people it really [ __ ]
with them is like we're talking about a
lot of movies they watch too many movies
fiction becomes non-fiction right
like that right they they watch way too
many [ __ ] movies um so we're gonna
finally we're 35 minutes in the second
hour do you have to bounce or you can
you stay for the show uh i gotta bounce
in a couple minutes okay so let's look
for one more topic
um because i really want to uh steve
scalise uh let's get your opinion on the
don't say gay bill why why we're here uh
midas
matt says i don't
say gay i live it i don't choose gay i
accept it and there will never be a day
when i'm not gay um thank you for for
your your tweet there matt
i think this is really ridiculous that
um people don't see the blatant fascism
here when when they're when when not
only not only are they saying you can't
you can't be gay but you can't even say
it right you can't even say it like we
made so much progress just to get to the
point right right like [ __ ] pulling
teeth from people
to get
where we are right now where it's like
oh you could have two people in a
relationship they're able to get married
they're able to get adopt you know they
adopt a child they're able to get health
care you know whatever it is
and now it's like oh nope we're going to
start repealing that stuff because
what's going to happen is now
you know
this i i don't know what would happen on
the federal like supreme court level but
someone i'm sure is gonna challenge this
and then it's gonna go to the supreme
court and then
you know the supreme court already ruled
that gay marriage was legal right so i
don't know what's going to happen with
this because i know this i mean it's the
same thing with having with the
anti-abortion stuff right like waiting
for someone to sue so they would take it
to federal court and get the supreme
court to actually
uh decide on something and and i'm sure
um this is going to somehow end up in uh
in front of the supreme court and or
it'll maybe it'll be dismissed i don't
know but i would fully expect
someone to fight this i mean everyone is
fighting this out other than republicans
because it's absolutely [ __ ]
disgusting and batshit crazy that we're
back at a point where it's like you
can't talk about you can't say it if
your kid comes to you to talk about it
you can't do it anyone who's trans that
is evil anyways well you know that
that's a good point because it does seem
like
unfortunately florida and texas are
having like a fascist off right yeah
like oh we're gonna do the don't say gay
bill and then texas is like oh well
we'll make sure that all trans people
including their parents and their
brothers and sisters and siblings are
also ostracized from society we will do
that we'll actually put them in jail if
someone even considers the idea of being
of identifying as trans
any kind of treatment that they may get
even uttered a word those parents could
be jailed and make sure that those
children be taken away from their
parents the trans children and the
non-trans children it really is [ __ ]
gross yeah it really is
a deep-seated [ __ ] fascism what what
i think is
most important for people to understand
is they will come for your [ __ ]
children too just because your children
aren't trans doesn't mean they won't
come for your children because they hold
empathy right if your children hold hold
empathy and they're anti-trump because
they hold empathy they're anti-bullies
because they hold empathy they will come
for your [ __ ] children too don't
think it will stop at
gay children and trans children they are
coming for children and it is it is
disgusting that they do this to
gays trans the lgbtq community uh david
hogg here has a video that he reached we
did of midas touch but he says students
across florida are walking out in
protest of desantis don't say gay bill
tweet out your support with let let free
florida say gay um and that's the the
point here is it's it's it's if this is
really truly about freedom to them then
the freedom should be your liberty and
the the
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not liberty it's in our [ __ ] intro
it's in our intro the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
liberty i want to show this video this
walkout
the bravery here
is heartwarming
that this next generation the gen z
um
not only not only supports
the rights of other people
but are willing to stand and shout and
protest
and cause good trouble against a bunch
of [ __ ] fascists
listen
don't look away
it's very heartwarming to see that that
that the young folks in this country are
willing to stand up for the rights of
other people um their friends their
family their community members that's
that's what patriotism is what you're
seeing right there in that video all you
freedom convoy people who think you're
going to fight freedom because i would
guarantee you if you went around to
every single one of those people in the
freedom convoy and ask them about the
freedom that florida is taking away i'm
sure they would be for taking the
freedom away of those floridians and
those children those [ __ ] it is
gross and disgusting but being able to
see
uh like you know i can only imagine what
it would be like to be in high school
right now or or you know just
to be in in the company of others who
also feel like
they're
they're uh
they themselves are being um
stolen right like their identity is
being stolen
by by people right this whole
generations gen z is is
is feeling like their voice is their
voice their control right the whole my
body my choice doesn't apply again it
does not apply
when it goes against the straight white
male conservative
uh person right like if it's ever
something that makes me feel
uncomfortable or makes me question my
beliefs or or makes me feel stupid in
any way because my ideologies and my
uh my way of thinking are wrong
then i have to say no you ban it
you jail them
you you burn it you kill like whatever
it is anything this is what that party
does they are the party that is
constantly in fear
of feeling uncomfortable
right and when they do
then they have to remove it they have to
shun it away they have to put it away in
a dark place whether it's they
themselves that feel this way personally
and they feel they can't be themselves
or it's someone else who who they don't
want to be able to feel that same way
that
they don't be able to feel free and and
feel like they can actually be truly who
they are and if they can't be happy then
why didn't the party then the party
itself can't be happy and that's what's
[ __ ] right especially especially
from a bunch of conservatives who say
like oh i'm gay and i don't have a
problem with this if you're watching
this
this should make you just this should
make you gross i would love to see what
someone like christian walker thinks
because that [ __ ] is completely [ __ ]
right well he he would probably be for
it um even though
uh he is openly gay um i know you have
to bounce i want to read this one last
tweet on the don't say gay bill uh aaron
parnan says to the thousands of high
school students in florida rallying
against the don't say gay bill know that
millions of florinians see you hear you
and stand with you 100
and i'd like to add to aaron's tweet
millions more americans see you many
more around the world see you and we
hear you and we stand with you and we
will continue to stand with you
regardless of what these fascists do
regardless of the laws they pass
we will we will try with pro-democracy
messaging and and to defeat these
fascists
at every turn and that's why we have to
stay pissed we have to have strategic
outrage um because let me tell you
something you want messaging against gas
prices you want messaging against gas
prices here it is folks here it is right
here forget your [ __ ] gas prices
they're coming after you they're coming
after your [ __ ] family that's what
they're coming after uh and gabe thanks
thanks for joining us i appreciate um uh
very exciting stuff gonna come in the
next in the next couple months um
we got a very exciting interview coming
up i hope we have uh one that is uh
edited sometime this week i don't know
if you
that's on the list or not we've been
very busy i understand yeah yeah so
we're we're going to try to get another
interview that we've had in the can for
a while get it out this week um but we
do have another one coming up actually
we have a couple of very exciting
interviews coming up uh that are really
exciting and i hope to
put those in the can as well so
good work here
you've done a fantastic job even though
you can't work the mic all the time it
doesn't that doesn't matter we're not
going to hold that against you the
artwork the graphics the video
um everyone give high-fives and clap for
gabe uh give him some love on the
twitter page uh we we we we have come a
long way my friend over the last what
three or four months i guess yeah since
here we are at whenever that first uh
that first midas touch interview was
when it was episode 50. well you know it
all it all started every everyone asked
several people have asked how did you
engage meet and i said twitter we met on
we met on twitter uh our bromance
started on twitter i interviewed gabe
and uh
it has our our our relationship has
blossomed from there and now our
engagement uh to midas touch has become
a marriage um and we're very excited
about it so everyone stay tuned um to
all all the things that are gonna come
from the podcast stick around gabe's uh
gabe you gotta bounce right yeah i gotta
go okay uh we'll stick around audience
i'll be back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] a [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us we are 47
minutes into the second hour
what an hour two hours excuse me two
hours it has been
uh we had a trucker from the trucker
convoy we had brett my zealous reminders
touch
we had a gate come in rachel bitkoffer
from strike pack to give us messaging
what a show today what a show i'm so
happy that you've joined us today and
and i hope all of you out there keep
joining us every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central right here on youtube
twitter twitch don't forget to subscribe
to the youtube channel if you are out
there and you're not subscribed yet
click the like button do all the things
you're supposed to do comment down below
um also to remind you we now have super
chat
anyone who's in the chat
who doesn't know what super chat is and
people who do explain that to him you
can actually help the podcast that our
time is
we do spend a lot of time at this
podcast and we're super excited to
finally have the chance to announce that
we have a super chat you have the chance
to now uh live
support the podcast you can either do a
super chat with money or with the
sticker
gail ask where
where is the super chat button um it's
down at the bottom it looks like uh the
little dollar bill
and you can click on that and that will
help you with the super chat or the
super stickers so thank you very much
for everyone who gave today in the super
chat um we will continue to try to pull
in your comments everyone's clapping for
gabe galen mj
um
uh mayo gave hearts for gabe robin says
thank you gabe uh hashtag pro democracy
um we
uh
christina says how does that work maybe
maybe what i'll do is um
i don't know we'll try to figure out
something maybe i'll tweet out like a
like a thing on how to do the super chat
i don't know i i i i'm not exactly sure
um mj i know uh and and midas lisa gave
to the super chat today so thank you
very much for your guys's contribution
to the podcast on the super chat
um and all of you listening out there uh
on the on the podcast i can't do super
chat on the auto podcast but if you want
to subscribe to the youtube channel you
can do super chat live you have to watch
it live but you can also go to
thetonymichaels.com
that's that's another way that you can
contribute to the show you can go to
thetonymichaels.com
we have our
our uh our [ __ ] merch there
there's my merch store there's gabe's
merch store there's also the podcast
upgrade fund so if you like to
contribute to the podcast in that form
also don't think that you have to give
um any anything as far as monetary we
love when you do it really helps out
because it is a lot of time and effort
to do this
with the podcast and now that we have
the midas touch we will we will be
amping up maybe even
by the summer if we need to
we could go to three hours a day i'm
just floating some stuff out there i'm
not saying it's all true but it may that
may come to pass but here's the thing if
you guys contribute um in your likes
shares
comments uh come join us live uh give us
a review on on your favorite podcast
directory even the band one spotify
which it looks like spotify is trending
by the way uh i don't know if it's
because they have outages or what but
spotify is trending speaking of band
or boycott excuse me
boycotted
podcast directories we are on spotify we
are an apple we are on google youtube
twitter twitch so go subscribe to all
your favorite channels wherever you're
at
whether you watch us whether you listen
to us uh stay tuned because
we're gonna have some big big interviews
we're gonna have some big big shows
um and i know being part of the midas
media network
is going to
give us a lot
a lot
of leverage to make sure that we
give you the best content that we
possibly can give uh gail thank you very
much
uh for the super chat
again i will try to uh bring you guys in
as you do the super chat
um as i noticed them sometimes sometimes
with the comments because it's gotten
more and more of you participate in the
comments sometimes it's hard to follow
um
uh caitlyn here has uh he was found
guilty on all charges i'm taking it
that's is that the first
uh someone sent me that tweet we'll pull
it up
maybe it's trending by now it sounds
like that's the um
the january 6 the first trial the first
verdict
that was taken to a jury
um
someone someone send me that tweet or
tag me and i'll try to pull that up but
we're 52 minutes into the hour so we got
a little bit
a little bit more time left here and
they're saying yes so i think that's
i think that's the case someone has been
found guilty on all charges
in the insurrection and a trial that the
the verdict
is guilty
guilty as charged i'm not sure who it is
or what the um
i'm not sure which one it is so maybe
we'll let's go back to the turn and turn
the tweet to each maybe we'll find it
here
um you can see spotify and discord is um
is trending number one it looks like
there's outages uh it is international
women's day i didn't want to bring that
up um
this share your favorite videos i love
the video of the ukrainian women
sending their children to safety and
then coming back and fighting the [ __ ]
out of the russians it's a fantastic
video you should go find that video it's
on my timeline and hashtag it with
international women's day uh you should
do that uh
do let's see if we can find
what's what's the name of the guy what's
the name of the guy
of the verdict what's what's his name
what's the name of the guy who just got
found guilty
what's his name
what's his name
what's his name
um
now i'm just singing
of course gas prices are still trending
joy read is trending
let's see if it's in the for you
where is it what's the name of this
person
guy
guy riff it is that is that you said
is it the name and is that the name
let's see if i can find it here
um this is how we do sometimes when we
have breaking news we get a
it looks like that might be it that
might be it
i'm not sure if i'm spelling it right
i don't know
that is the one tony that is the one
riff it
let's see if we can just search it that
way
i'm gonna find it here
[Music]
arrested by fbi
there isn't a lot of news yet
search
search
msnbc
okay i'll search msnbc to see if we can
find the video
of this guy with his conviction
anybody in the dm
oh here we go
i've got a dm here maybe
oh
copy
i think i've got a story here paste
enter
okay
uh tom jackman here has breaking guy
riff riffit is that how you say his name
riffit guilty on all counts in the
january 6
um capital trial
christina thank you for the super
sticker thank you for the super sticker
christina
i love the super stickers okay um
guilty on all counts
um i'm not sure what the counts are
here is the the story from the
washington post we will
we will um retweet this so you guys can
go take a look at that
um
that is the
the guy
i'm not sure what was his charges do you
guys know what charges he was found
guilty on and how many
i can pull up the washington post
article here but it might just be easier
let's just let's just search let's do
this
let's do this for everyone listening i'm
gonna search
guy riffit
guilty
um
new on all five counts so there's five
counts ryan
reilly here uh clean sweep for doj
so doj one on all five counts that's
really a bad sign for anyone else um
what also this means probably here's
aaron parnez uh guy rific has just been
found guilty on all charges in the
january fir in the first january 6th
related trial great day um
the other thing that's very significant
about this
is that um not only
will this uh cause
um rifts inside of other prosecutions
but it will scare folks and what i mean
by that is people who are charged and
see that oh my god this guy got all
counts
all counts because here's the thing when
you don't do a deal that's why 99 of
federal cases they do a plea deal and
the reason why is because when you go to
trial the judge the judge doesn't take
it easy on you
like when you go all the way through the
trial and there's
a jury and all that kind of stuff the
judge doesn't normally take it easy on
you um but in a plea deal that is
normally the case like they're like oh
we'll give you leniency because you're
you know you're taking a plea you're
you're
you're you're
participating you're cooperating right
they give you cooperation points
not here
not here um so it looks like and i think
this is the picture of the guy
trying to find a good picture we get
articles here
but i want to pull the picture
um
there there he is there there's this guy
here's this guy
um caitlyn said he brought a gun into
the capitol
so that may be one of the charges that
he's convicted on is bringing a weapon
of course uh in dc though the weapons
laws are a little different that's why
the
[Music]
terrorist oath keepers had the qrf
the stash of guns across the potomac and
not
in
it to dc and kept them off
um
well
so that's good news good news in the uh
in
the january sixth front that should make
some folks happy that there's now
not only people pleading guilty but
there's prosecutions by juries now we'll
wait to see what the sentencing is i
doubt the judge will sentence him right
away that's possible i guess it could it
could happen that way uh other other
january six news again enrico terrio
uh tario tario um he is um
been indicted uh scott has it here flash
proud boys leader enrique terrio was
indicted on capital riot conspiracy the
feds say although is not accused of
physically taking part in the breach of
the capital the indictment alleges that
he led the advancing planning and
remained in contact with other members i
think that is very significant as well
today so big january 6 insurrection news
for the department of justice not only
in indictments but also in
convictions from a
jury thanks for joining us here
um on episode 91 the very first midas
touch partner episode keep joining us
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
twitch don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel um that is super
important to stay
in touch with all these videos you can
also go to the twitch channel you can
watch us on twitter follow us on twitter
at tonymichaelspod we always do the
bonehead of the week poll over there on
the podcast page
and go to thetonymichaels.com check out
some [ __ ] merch
and thanks for being in the super chat
everyone today thank you very much for
all the super stickers and the super
chats today really do appreciate the
support the likes the retweets
and until tomorrow at noon eastern
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking